let's now consider how to find the
velocity of the center of mass of a
wheel that's rolling without slipping
down an inclined plane so let's draw a
picture here's the wheel it starts at T
equals zero and this is an angle C and
at some later time T final the wheel has
dropped a distance H along the inclined
plane and now let's figure out what is
the velocity of the center of mass of
the wheel when it gets to the bottom and
we are now going to apply our energy
arguments now the first thing we have to
realize is is a very subtle point here
is that there can be friction and we saw
that when a wheel is rolling without
slipping there can be static friction
between ethylic instant the contact
point between the wheel and the ground
there is a gravitational force and a
normal force now static friction does no
work because the point is always
instantaneously at rest and f dot d s is
zero because the object is at rest and
so the D s is zero so our static
friction does no work and therefore from
our energy principle that the external
work equals e final minus V initial we
have no external work and so our energy
is constant now how do we analyze our
energy
well I've set things up so I'm going to
choose my potential energy to be zero
when it's at the bottom and that our
initial energy is only equal to
potential energy if the wheel has a mass
and
gravitational force down the potential
energy initially is MGH the final energy
is only kinetic energy the wheel is
rolling with omega final its center of
mass is moving with V center of mass
final and we just saw that the kinetic
energy has two contributions the
translational kinetic energy one-half M
we'll just call this final squared and
we'll make that V final just to make it
easier and it has the kinetic energy of
rotation now the rolling without
slipping condition is that the
translational center of mass speed is
equal to the radius of the wheel R times
the angular speed Omega final so I can
write e final as one-half M plus IC M
over R squared times the final squared
where I'm just replacing Omega final
equals V final over R and therefore that
the kinetic energy by the energy
principle tells us that initial equals e
final so MGH equals one-half times M
plus IC M over R squared V final squared
so we can find that V final is equal to
the square root of 2mg H divided by M
plus 1/2 cm R squared and that is the
final speed of the center of mass
translational velocity of the wheel as
it dropped a height H